you were you are a director who did some
small films what had he done before I've
made a three documentaries before
meeting on by the way a great
documentary called GG Allin you saw it
remember that was Todd's film that's
great yeah I love that film and also you
did some other you know stuff nobody
ever heard of frat house which I've seen
part of actually this morning I watched
some of it it's really good yeah that
one at the Sundance Film Festival which
is where I met Ivan you for the first
time well let me tell you something frat
house is great because actually todd
goes and you know and he has to get into
a frat uh-huh and they haze him at one
point they lock him in a dog cage and
they throw like tobacco spit on them on
him and they what else do they do they
throw like like I mean I mean it was
grown at the time and we got thrown out
of one fraternity we were filming so we
made a deal at another fraternity that
we would go through the process if we
could film it it's disgusting it's
really funny and you can't and you can't
get that film released I would watch
that film it's great it is a great film
what did you go there's one great scene
where they keep taking him in the
pledges to the basement and blindfolding
them and getting them in their underwear
right and and they keep throwing like
ravioli on them and vomit yeah and Todd
you did this for the film you decided
yeah all these macho kind of guys all
doing weird stuff to you and this was a
this was real stuff you didn't staged it
for the camera well no and that's what
the what the kids come out they claim
they say they were drunk and stoned when
they signed releases which is true give
them coffee and sober them up and wait
right but uh yeah so you know that's
that's the status of that movie is still
up in the air and I'm sure this won't
and so I've been you spotted these films
and you said here's a guy I'd like to
see the Sundance Film Festival because
my son had to fill out a short playing
there right and he says you know you
should see frat house it's great it's
really funny I think they dig it and
it's not so much to animal house and
right Andrew and I at the time said
we're gonna make a documentary version
of Animal House I mean that was the goal
and I think there's a lot of comedy and
so Ivan took the hand of God because
Ivan is known as God in LA and he
touched you and said the intent you
you out touch you in an appropriate
place but he touched you and he said I'm
gonna let you have a shot at making a
film I believe in you yeah no one
believed in you did that nobody no no we
we Ivan actually and I sat down we
started talking about movies and talking
about Animal House and he's and he said
you know the the road trippin Animal
House was always sort of a thing he he
thought can be further explored as a
feature right I hooked up with Scott and
we went off and wrote it and I even
liked it Ivan is a stickler on the
script you know that he doesn't like
many scripts yeah you directed their
commercials yeah you did is that
lucrative so if I go direct to
commercial how much money can I get from
doing a Pepsi commercial that would be
the creme de la cuddly buy a house in
Oyster Bay really it's a lot of money so
you know what you're doing with a camera
you're not some goofball that that's but
he had never done a narrative film so
that was really the that was the that
was the lead Ivan took Ivan for you it
as hard as a producer to find someone
that you believe in that you would back
and usually I know you hate these guys
after you finish working with them but
the most porcupine here uqu most of the
time it's tough much the time stuff and
yet you guys like each other after
shooting one movie you are bonding you
like each other in fact you know our
company the Montecito picture company
just made another deal with Todd to do
what to write and direct another what
are you gonna write an overall deal but
yet I'm writing another comedy it's not
a teen comedy Ivan what if this one
doesn't do well will you dump Todd very
quickly very very you will alright so
the deal will dry up for two more years
there's a great guy but I'll never
forget the day that we were here in
Manhattan in some hotel and they were
beginning to cut private parts and
everybody said Ivan is coming everybody
started shaking in their boots they were
almost in tears
Ivan yells a lot that's not true yeah it
is actually new I've seen the young
people
ivenn if the movie doesn't do well which
I predict it will do well but let's say
doesn't Todd we'll still get to make
another movie for you yes boy you really
believe in this guy now this this film
has really worked out great well you'll
do well there's nothing like it around